une longue attente avant l'embarquement
à kaboul et un confort minimum à bord de
cet avion militaire ukrainien
mais qu'importe ces afghans se savent
sauver
l'arrivée à kiev est un étang
soulagement après des semaines
d'angoissé pour jawad haqmal un ancien
interprète des forces armées canadiennes
car il était désespéré lorsqu'il a vu
les derniers soldats canadiens partir de
kaboul sans lui
contre toute attente c'est aux forces
spéciales ukrainienne que jawad doit son
salut des soldats d'élite qui sont
sortis du périmètre de l'aéroport
pour escorter ces minibus dans lequel
ils prenaient place sous le feu des
talibans
jawad a bénéficié d'un heureux concours
de circonstance car cette opération
était d'abord planifié pour sauver des
interprètes du global est une initiative
du journaliste mexicaine après avoir
tenté en vain d faire secourir par des
soldats canadiens
le journaliste a fait jouer ses contacts
une opération à hauts risques validé en
haut lieu
mais tish
encore l'os et c'est gênant comme
canadien devra faire sa job le pardon
si le canada est reconnu comme une
grande nation donc tu convaincu qu'on
arrive femmes
jérémy verville est un ancien capitaine
des forces canadiennes déployées dans la
région de kandahar en 2009 jawad haqmal
était son interprète son ami ils ont
risqué leur vie ensemble
faire la guerre avec des individus la
relation se transforme transcende le
professionnalisme un peu c'est ce lien
cette amitié qui est poussé jérémy
verville à s'impliquer pour tenter
d'aider de wade aille mal financièrement
entre autres
car deux mois après son départ de kaboul
l'ancien interprète est toujours à kiev
en ukraine ce qui ne devait être en
principe qu'une courte escale en route
vers le canada s'est éternisé à
contre temps qu'il ne comprend pas car
son dossier d'immigration est complet
depuis le mois d'août
depuis deux mois jawad est forcé de
vivre dans cette chambre d'hôtel à kiev
avec les membres de sa famille
une chambre pays par marc paquin une
situation que le journaliste ne
s'explique pas non plus we want
délai qui étonne aussi les autorités
ukrainiennes
si ottawa on refuse de commenter le
capitaine jérémy verville lui tire déjà
ses conclusions c'est une drôle d'image
qu'on laisse si on projette on va
quelque part au sable des ressources en
place puis après ça on les abandonne
c'est pas comme canadiennes et canadiens
c'est au nom d'un idéal commun que ce
canadien et sept afghans ont porté
fièrement il y à 12 ans le même uniforme
pour tous puis ils sont réunis par une
même amertume une même déception avec
l'impression désagréable que les valeurs
qu'ils ont défendu ensemble ont beaucoup
été bafoués dans ce dossier